we're gonna begin with this it's a new
CBS News poll YouGov poll finds Joe
Biden is holding on to his lead in the
pack of Democratic presidential nominees
but the former bless you but the former
vice president's advantage is shrinking
in the early primary states political
correspondent ed O'Keefe is in
Washington with more on this story so ed
I'm curious about this what else did we
learn from this latest set of polling
sure Gail well look it's now easier to
group the candidates into three distinct
tiers former Vice President Joe Biden
and Senators Elizabeth Warren Kamala
Harris and Bernie Sanders are in that
first tier indiana mayor Pete Budaj edge
former congressman benoît Florrick and
former HUD secretary Julian Castro are
in that second tier everyone else polls
at 1% or less and they're on the third
tier Warren and Harris and Sanders
especially are gaining ground now mainly
because each top-tier candidate has
carved out their own niche I believe we
are literally not figuratively in the
balance for the soul of the country the
survey finds that most Democrats are
more concerned about hearing from
candidates and how they defeat President
Trump next year not how they differ from
their primary opponents and that's what
makes Biden tops he's the first choice
of Democrats in the early States three
and four Democrats considering Biden say
he would beat mr. Trump a higher number
than those considering his opponents and
Biden's backers want someone with a more
polite and civil tone catching up or
Massachusetts senator Elizabeth Warren
and California Senator Kamala Harris
fading back a bit Vermont senator Bernie
Sanders wall street is sucking value out
of the rest of the economy
Warren is now considered the candidate
who will fight the most for people we
got to put a stop to that and Harris is
now considered the most strong thanks to
her standout debate performance last
month
do you agree today that you were wrong
to oppose busing in America on the
issues health care leads but it's the
cost that concerns voters most Democrats
support a medicare-for-all health care
plan first pushed by Sanders it is
absurd that we remain the only major
country on earth not to
guarantee healthcare to all people but
more than four and ten say they oppose
Medicare for all like Biden does or
first want to learn more about the
potential costs well that's what this to
us with this cave days about you to very
people want Medicare for all of
marketplace so it's getting harder for
many of those lesser known third tier
candidates to raise money and attract
attention and multiple people in the now
concede to CBS News that some of them
are likely to drop out at some point
after next week's debates likely by the
end of the summer all right some really
interesting results there ed thank you
very much